Yes, sir. Can I help you?
Hi, checking out of room 809, please.
Yes, sir. Was everything satisfactory, sir?
Yeah. Look, I'm sorry, I'm in a hurry.
I'm running late for a flight, so if we could speed this up...
I just need to review your account...
...and have you sign the room rate and the incidentals, sir.
Fine.
One night at a standard rate: 119 dollars.
Okay, yes.
State tax comes to 9 dollars and 52 cents.
Okay.
Facility fee: 15 dollars.
It's fine, I don't care.
I just need to get to the airport.
So, you can just put it on the credit card that you have on file.
We don't want to overcharge you, sir.
Three-minute phone calls: 4 dollars and 22 cents.
Okay, that's right.
One dinner buffet billed to the room: 15 dollars.
Sure.
One glass of red wine with the buffet: 9 dollars.
Okay, this all sounds fine. Look, I really have to go, I have a cab waiting.
Your receipt is printing.
Okay, I don't need a receipt.
It's nearly printed.
And it's jammed, sir.
I'll print you another.
That's okay, don't worry about it.
And look at that! I missed my flight!
Will you be needing lodging tonight, sir?
Yes, please.
All right, let's go through that one more time.